au procès de jean marie villemin devant
la cour d'assises de côte-d'or les
experts en écriture qui se sont succédé
aujourd'hui à la barre ont fait passer
une bien mauvaise journée à son épouse
christine compte rendu d'audience
dominique verdeilhan gillard à gries
depuis le début du procès christine
villemin avait pris soin de rester
muette et sereine devant les caméras
mais ce midi il y a eu sa première
petite phrase c'est de nouveau 85
l'époque où la presse et la justice
étaient après christine villemin parce
que d expert en graphologie l'a désigné
comme étant le corps au des experts qui
depuis hier je reformule leur analyse
celle où il souligne des similitudes
extraordinaire quant aux avocats de
bernard laroche
ils prennent soin que christine villemin
soit bien installée pour suivre les
dépositions des experts
je peux carrément aller dans le box
lance-t-elle irrité au président
quelques peu déboussolé audience
troublante pour les jurés face à cet
expert qui désigne christine villemin et
trois autres qui accule bernard laroche
qui dit vrai qui est crédible
la défense elle n'a qu'une seule réponse
christine villemin a bénéficié d'un
non-lieu en février dernier et voici que
plus le procès avance plus on s'écarte
de ce pourquoi jean marie villemin est
jugé mais depuis trois semaines le
président lee virus ans ne cesse de
répéter qu'il ira jusqu'au bout qu'il ne
vois pas comment on pourrait arrêter
cette marche à un moment donné et qu'il
n'y a que comme ça que la vérité puisse
être approché la défense découvre
aujourd'hui les effets pervers de cette
nouvelle instruction le dossier grégory
est remis à plat à dijon et certaines
pages noires de la sphère remontent à la
surface